豊臣秀之 天下一のぶっ飛びマシーン 千葉県出身
織田慎太郎 セオリー無視の一発屋 千葉県出身
徳川康兵衛 麻雀理論を全く持たない タコなき男 千葉県出身
明智光一 超合理的理論麻雀を打つ 試合校舎 千葉県出身
早見明一郎豊臣の恋人
驚異的な月の文字主
千葉県出身
やっぱりプールは真冬に限るぜ
めんたま生き返るっぺ
あれを見ろよ
オーエクセレント
ブラボー
おまきなおさま
たまらんぱい
あきなきゃ
よ、シシ!
はーい
アクションチョンチョーン
失礼します
それ!
勝ち!
こき!こき!こき!
きっと!
やっほー!
なによこれ?
なまこだ!巨大な赤なまこが、2匹くっついてるんだ!
バカ、ここは海じゃねえなの?
近寄るな!離れて、離れて!
マジ!誰が赤な膜やねん!
失礼だな、まったく。のんびり泳ぐこともできやしない。
部屋に帰って寝る
どういう泳ぎ方してたんだあいつ
きっと海底原人ラゴンよ
あら豊臣くん
何してんだそこで
だってみんな先に行っちゃうんだもん
おめえがトロトロしてっから悪いだろうが
豊臣くんも泳いできたら気持ちいいわよ
それよりなんか冷てえもんでも飲みてえな
あ、豊臣、いつまでも突っ立ってないで
なんか買ってこいよ
私が行ってくるわ
いいからいいから、秋名ちゃんは座ってなって
おい、こうだな、4本頼むぞ
1、2の、ちゃんの、き
あんだよ、早く行けよ
4本分しかないよ
そう言っただめ、耳ついてねえかおめえ
僕のは?
甘えてねえよ。そのぐらい自分で出すだよ。
自分でって、一銭もないのしてるくせに。
あ、泣いちったこいつ。二十歳過ぎてコーラ一本で泣いちった。
だったらリゾートホテルなんかに無理してついてくんじゃねえ。
私がおごってあげるわ。
アキナちゃん、甘えかすとクセになるぜ
はい、好きなもの買ってらっしゃい
アキナちゃーん!
ええ、情けねえやつ
おっちゃん、コーラくれ、ごほーん
はいよ
サンキュー
あ、あなたは?
小沢竹書房師匠
小沢竹書房
泣く子も振り込む必殺技
無花粉打法の使い手としてその名を轟かした
何度死んでも控える不死身のチャンシである
師匠、生きて、生きておられたんですね
はて、何のことかの
また、とぼけちゃって、この、この
おぬしわしをだれかとかんちがいなされておりようじゃな
わしはおざわどかゆださーいなではない
じゃあなんなのなんなのかな
うせてねうせて
こうなかったらとっととむこうへいきなされ
にどとこのばいてんにちかづかんでもらおう
よろしいな
パン!
疲れ!
何?
退屈中
ほらほら、置いたしちゃダメよ
あっちへ行ってなさい
次、混ぜて
何言ってるんだ、今オラ忙しいんだ
おめえなんかに用はねえだよ
わあ、いい手だね
余計なお世話だ
わあ、それ着るの?
僕だったらこっち切るな。そして、これを落としていったほうが役が確定するもん。
ほらね。
言った通りにしときゃ、数話待ちの天前じゃ。
リーチ!
リーチ!そんなの絶対ダメだよ!
そうか。
一発相撲!リーチ即相撲!パン屋を三色!
乗った!ウラウラ!
- バイマンだ!- そんな・・・
- 何か?- ええ、べ、べつに・・・
- めくんなよ、おめえ!- リーチ!
しまった!アンパイがない!
よーし、一点読み!
アキナちゃんの町はズバリ、サブロー湾だ!
- サブロー湾町か?- サブロー湾!
よし!じゃあ、サブロー湾!
じゃあ、三番!
どうしよう。
よかったぜ。本当に安牌がなかったんだけどさ。
トヨタミの一点読みなら、まず間違いなく外れるからな。
まったく、現物に等しい安牌だぜ。
もう!邪魔しないでよ、トヨタミ君!
僕は別にそんな・・・
おろおろ、邪魔だっぺ。子供はさっさと寝るだよ。
楽しいな!
つまんない
なんだ?
これは!
こんなものを拾っちゃった
このホテルのディナー付き宿泊券じゃない
届けたほうがいいよね
そうね
さあ、トヨトミ、マージャンやるぞ
ほら、抜けっからおめえやればいいだよ
で、でも、これ届けなきゃ
いや、あとあとあとでいいの、はいはい、サクサクやるべ、サクサクとな、はいはいはい
バカな、あいつに勝ってディナー宿泊券は俺がいただくぜ
トヨトミのやつめ、いいもん持ってきてくれたぜ
おめえらが帰った後は、アキナちゃんと二人だけで過ごせるってわけだ
へへ、こうなる、こうなる、へへへへ
おっと、これまたいいハイパイだぜ
ポンだぜ!
おお、コンバットマーチが聞こえてくるぜ
引いた!リュウイソテンパイ!
この受けだと小袖5200だ
酸素ないて酸素炭気の方が
通素ポンだけに上がりやすい
行けー
出たぜ
タイヤを3色
イーペーコードラドラ
あんた、おらとやる前にぶっ飛んでっちまっため
ディナー付き宿泊券が手に入るのも
時間の問題だな
トヨタミ君
ない
もしかして
豊臣が拾った豪華ディナーショー付き宿泊ご招待券
その持ち主であるらしいこの怪しげな人物は
ひょっとして死んだはずの小沢武書房ではないのか
そしてこの後豊臣と秋名には
どんな結末が待ち受けているというのだろうか
怒涛の後半は今からおよそ80秒後
一度心して待て
さてと逆転の手作りはどこ
逆転
おめえ箱下6万からどうやって逆転するつもりだよ
逆転なんつー人並みの単語を使用すんじゃねーよ
まあまあまあまあ誰だって夢を持つくらいはいいじゃない
そりゃそうだ、こいつも一個の人権ツーも持ってんかんな
そうさ、カエルだって、オケラだって、アメンボだって、みんなみんな生きてっかんな
そうだ、友達なんだよ
バカにするな!
よっしゃー!見とれー!
よっしゃー!来たー!
4層を切れば、1ピン3層のシャボ
3層を切れば、2数層のリャンベンマッチ
こっちで、リーチだ!
一発で積もって裏ドラ3つ乗れば倍満だ!
そしたら一気に!
爆発した!4万4千点だぜ!
利金で言うことか、それって。
うりゃー!積もれー!
何それ?
うりゃー!
酸素を切ってりゃ、一発で積もってた!
パッコンだ!
おっと、始まったぜ。
上がればトップだ!
寝たぞー。おありがとーござーい。
何者だおめーは!
リーッチ!
ん?その後に続く言葉はねーのか?
なんだ、リーの実か?
バカめー!フラドラ見てホエスラかくなよ!
ドライッチ!
うーらうーら、ホエスラかけかけ!
はいはい、ホエスラですよ。ホエホエー。
へえ、あたが26だろうが。
違う!残忍!残忍!テンパネしてんだろ!
よく見てよ、お客さん。困るよ、点数ごまかされちゃ。
こいつら商売に何人だよな、そんなんじゃ。
50分だよ、50分!
うっせえな!26でも残忍でも、おめえのマイナス107は変わんねえだろうが!
ハーフタイム。
torment
痛い!
ロン、まんがんだ。
なにすんだ豊臣!
い、いま、変なものがマドの外に!
ん Jeremy and Scientist
どこにもなんにもそんなもんおらんぞ。
やー今、たしかにいたんです。
夢でもみたでねーか、おめー。
おかしいな。
たく、ひと騒がせな奴だぜ。
いい加減にしろよな。
ち!
お前らは誰じゃ!
違うだろ!
あんた一体誰なんだ?
待てよ。
どっかで見たことあるな。
あった!小沢竹書房だ!
はい、正解!ありがとう、シャン。
師匠!
師匠、お懐かしゅうございます。
おー、弟子か。
やっぱり屋台の汚いじじいは師匠だったですね。
おぬしら、麻雀をしていたようじゃのう?
はい。師匠もはんちゃんどうですか?
ぜひ、師匠の実力を彼らに見せてやってください。
そうじゃのう。
さあさ、おじいちゃんどうぞ。
おぉ、せっかくじゃから、ちょいと呼ばれていくとするかのぉ。
おぉ、いいもんじゃのぉ。パイを握る感触というものはのぉ。
なになに?ふむふむ。
あ、そうかそうか。それを切れと申すか。
よしよし。
ブツブツ独り言言ってるぞ。
どうしとってっかな。
違う!
ワシくらいになると、パイの声が聞こえるようになるのじゃ。
パイの声?
さようパイにも心があって生きておる
常識にとらわれず水が流れるがごとく
パイの言う通りに生きることができてこそ
本物のジャンスと言えようぞ
さすが師匠
私もパイの音を聞いてみよう
あなたは亀を信じますか
つまんないこと言ってる間にリーチだぜ
ん若い人はとかくリーチを焦りなさる
おほほほほほどれどれほうも
なるほどお主の町はサブローピンじゃの
どうじゃズボシじゃろ
な、なんでそんなことがわかるんですか
す、すげえだ
ほほほステハイにもまた声がある
ステハイがサブローピン町だとわしに教えてくれとるのじゃよ
おほほほほほほ
一発!
リーチ一発!タンヤオイーペーコー!
若いの、おぬし、いい死に方、せんぞう
あら
ロン!ピーフイッツーゴンニー
ハロー!
ロン!メンホントンマンガンホロー!
ロン!リーチチャンタサンシャクドラドラ
お主たちにはか弱い老人をいたわるという気持ちがないのか
こんな若者見たことない
ごめんなさい
気にすることないって
これで師匠のラスはほぼ決まりだぜ
ここらで俺が一発
3位確定
甘い甘いぞ豊臣
師匠としてわざわざお主がこの隙を突いて向かってくるのを
わしは密かに待っておったのじゃ
ノイケツリーシー
な、なんなんですかそれは
知りてえか
いやさ、こいつの意味を
よいか
ノイケツはある日突然に襲ってくる
そして
ってぃ
食ったら確実にぶっ倒れるのじゃ
えぇ!?
えぇ!カロリーが高い!
のーい!ケツ!
ほれ、みー
カロリーの取りすぎに気をつけにはいかんと言うだろうに
ほっほっほっほっほっほ。
おっと、またてんばってしもうた。これでリーチじゃ。
えっ?
ちょ、ちょっと!そのまちは。だって、じいさん、見てみなよ。ほら!
おっ、おしょうか、あしょうか。まあ、だいじょうぶだよ、にほっほっほっほ。
一発つもろうじんぼけたんたんたんき。
ふりてんたんきまち!
つもるか、そんなの!
なろう若者の意地を見せてやるぜ
クモマッカ湿血リーチ
追っかけ社会保障
おや
超特急老人ホーム返し
リーチ一発メンホン賞賛言バイマン
若者の勝利だな
ヒギ寝たきり老人
ごまかすでね
お師匠
どうやらお迎えが来たようじゃ
なんかせめてその前にホテルのディナーが来たかった
な、なに?そ、それならここに
ああ、それは俺とアキラちゃんだ
ん?
お、こ、これは
わしがなくした豪華ディナー賞付き宿泊ご招待券5名様分ではないか
え?
えええええ
お主、ネコババするつもりであったな
いやー、料理はうめーし、ショーは最高だし、言うことねーぜ
うめだ
それにしてもジンさん、俺達を招待してくれて、サンキュー
なになに、人間悪事さえ働かなければ皆友達じゃよ
俺もっと食えもっと
トヨタミ君
さて続いては今夜の特別企画
恐怖の火男
ミスタースケッカー
僕は無実だ
トヨタミの心の叫びは
燃え盛る貧乏ダンスの炎と
観客の歓声によって
かき消されていったのである
豊臣よ君にこの言葉を贈ろう
花に嵐のたとえもあるさ
さよならだけが人生だ
なんちゃって
夜な夜な豊臣くんのアパートに現れては
麻雀をやっていく三人の男たち
豊臣くんの命が危ない
次回 階段図鑑道路
私は上がりたい きっと見てね 眠っちゃいや
セクが騒ぐな慌てるな
ファイルを掴めば専属のマンの夢が湧く
運風天風と理想が来る
飛べてくるんだ対面者
掴むといかねばならぬのだ
リジーとフィブリッツ
しばちゃかみちゃまじゃん仲間
勝負かけたら情けないのだ
君はアゲマンの主席じゃないか
僕のワンガンソロを呼ぶ
掴むと幸せ掴もうぞ
スーパースタート
やりでやりのまんまくところ
飛んでやりながら
ここは三面町どころ
行くぜカンキャン
おしむそこのせきがはだ
スーパーにいこうま
ゲングルにやりぬいて
買って飲み干すビールがうまい
スカッと
おたかまいのちがけ
ご視聴ありがとうございました